a few months back when the RTX 4080 12
gig I mean 4070 TI launched while we
could get graphics card for under the
suggested MSRP here in Malaysia for the
very first time reviewers in the US like
liners have reported an entirely
different story altogether this time it
seems like Nvidia has tightened its
range and set two separate launch dates
for the RTX 4070 today for graphics
cards that follow the suggested MSRP and
another one tomorrow for those that just
don't want to play ball in my opinion
and yours too probably at 349 ring the
RTX 4070 is the true mid-range card that
people are actually looking for so let's
just compare it to the 4070 TI and 4080
as well as L gen 3080 to see if you
should whip out your wallet to grab one
we got gaming benchmarks R tracing dlss
Puget bench and a lot so let's get King
looking at Market sentiments towards
these new gpus when I say midrange I
mean barely just barely personally I
wouldn't pay above MSRP for a 4070 where
value for money is going to play a more
crucial part in terms of a purchase
consideration which is why I decided to
check out the Asus dual model instead
specs wise the 4070 has 23.5% less Cuda
RT and tensor course when compared to
the 4070 TI but the exact same spec in
terms of vram it also has a lower tgp or
total Graphics power which makes it uh
actually more appealing towards
mid-range Gamers who don't necessarily
want to upgrade their power supply units
just to slot in a new GPU compared to
the last gen 3070 though the core counts
remain exactly the same we are getting
updated third gen RT cores and fourth
gen tensor course as well as a new Ada
love La architecture the vram has also
been bumped up quite a bit in terms of
quantity and also speed which is very
important at higher gaming resolutions
all the while keeping a lower power draw
which is you know great judging by that
MSRP the 4070 seems more appropriately
positioned in the mid-range when
compared to the TI and if it performs on
par with the RTX 3080 it would provide
us with decent value for money fun fact
I've never actually owned or even
touched uh an Asus dual graphics card
before because I'm a bangaan and also
because they just look very basic and
not my cup of tea which is why when I
did the ASMR unboxing for this Asus dual
RTX 4070 I was actually pleasantly
surprised with the card even though I
wasn't a big fan of that eco-friendly
packaging while it doesn't come with RGB
this dual material fan shout that is
clear on top and also matte black for
the rest with a you know nice back plate
to match just looks sliek AF to top
things off that dual fan combo as well
as that sizable heat sink managed to
keep the card relatively cool during our
stress test while staying very quiet to
be honest it just looks like the perfect
card to stick into an ITX build if
you're interested in this particular
graphics card feel free to check out the
links in the description as it will
support us to make more videos like this
but won't cost you anything extra before
we jump into the benchmarks these are
the specs to our test bench
[Music]
taking a look at the numbers starting
off with 3D Mark test it is evident that
the new RTX 470 has been beefed up
considerably in terms of pure
restoration performance compared to last
gen we're seeing up to a 23% uplift over
the RTX 3070 and numbers that are neet
inet with the 3080 compared to the 4070
TI however there is still a respective
22 to 37% gap which seems to justify the
16 plus% price difference next we tested
eight different games do note that for
this card 1080p scores are largely
irrelevant but I still included them in
case you are curious firstly we have
Shadow of Tomb Raider where you can see
performance scaling that is similar to
the time spy test uh which is again
mirrored by cyberp Punk 2077 interesting
enough the performance Gap is narrowed a
little uh with Horizon zero Dawn and
Dying Light to death trening is again
being an odd ball that showed very minor
differences between all cards with newer
titles like the recent Resident Evil 4
remake uh we even saw the 4070
outperforming the 3090 by 133% in 1440p
and within three frames per second in 4k
something else that you should pay
attention to is how much better this new
card is compared to the 370 in terms of
4K gaming we managed to hit over 60
frames per second for all games other
than the notorious cyberpunk 2077
finally for those who are mainly playing
FPS titles like Doom Eternal or valerant
uh there's really no point in upgrading
now Ray tracing is one of the main
reasons why you might consider the
switch to the newer 40 series so let's
take a closer look in Shadow of the Tomb
Raider with dlss off the RTX 4070 is 40
plus% slower than the 4070 TI uh which
was kind of expected due to the lower RT
core count but it pulled ahead from the
3070 by up to
23% uh in fact it was even faster than
the 380 in all resolutions by switching
on dlss you're closing the performance
Gap with the ti by up to a warping
20% in cyberp Punk while the 470 TI is
still the arguably better card for 4K
the 4070 still got us relatively
respectable numbers that are miles ahead
of the 3070 the lower vram on the 3070
really showed its age in 4k especially
surprisingly when you switch on DL SS uh
the 4070 is pretty much neck in neck
with even the 1390 so if 1440p and even
4K rage racing is what you're interested
in especially with newer AAA titles that
support dlss there is really no reason
not to consider the upgrade uh from the
307 I even tested Ray tracing in
Resident Evil 4 remake which uh is
honestly not the most stable at the
moment uh it also doesn't support dlss
so we can just take a look at the pure R
tracing performance as you can see the
4070 is giving us almost double the
frames per second as the 3070 in fact
the 3070 Flatout crashes every time I
try to run the game in 4k for
productivity workloads we are going to
start with Puget bench if you mostly use
Photoshop After Effects and Premier Pro
I would just skip the 4070 as it only
performed up to 11% better than the 370
which is quite a bit cheaper now however
with tasks like Da Vinci resolve that
utilizes more vram uh that 20% uplift
over the 3070 would definitely be worth
looking at for 3D work on the other hand
the 4070 is quite a bit better than the
uh 3070 with a performance increase of
around
25% overall only upgrade to the 4070 in
terms of productivity task if you work
with 3D or need that extra vram finally
since I've already shown you the thermos
and acoustic numbers just now let's take
a look at power consumption looking at
Power draw I think that a safe PSU spec
to pair this cart with would be around
550 to 650 Watts depending on your CPU
and other Hardware where with our system
with the I9 139900 k a safer bat will be
around 650 WS of course uh in my opinion
there is no overkill for PSU uh only
budget
constraints so the RTX 470 is it any
good and which among us should or
shouldn't consider the upgrade firstly
for gamers if you care about rate
tracing and you're coming from an older
graphics card up to even an RTX 3080
just go for it if you don't care about
rate tracing I would skip it if you
already own something that is RTX 3080
and up but I would still upgrade if
you're coming from a 3070 if you care
about 1440p and 4K gaming because of
that significant vrand bump especially
considering how much 1440p and 4K
displays have really come down in price
recently next if you want a game in 4k
and your game supports dlss then the
4070 would still be a good buy if not
especially with older games or console
ports then you would still have to game
in 1440p if you want to play at Max
settings for productivity purposes I
would only consider upgrading if you're
coming from a 3060 TI and under uh that
uplift from the 3070 is still not big
enough to Warrant an upgrade for the
most part just keeping it real if you've
been following us then you'll realize
that I have basically snoozed on the 407
DTR why because I really thought that it
was a very very awkward launch that I
couldn't be bothered covering if you
already considering a 4070 TI you might
as well just pay a little bit more for
the RTX 480 but that's just my heart
take okay this RTX 4070 however is
really closer to what mid-range Gamers
actually ask for we are getting a huge
jump in performance over the 3070 at a
still pretty decent price point if you
buy it closer to the MSRP that is also
considering the lower power draw you
would have no issues buying this and
just strapping it into your existing
build without upgrading your PSU for the
most part and if you get something
smaller like this Asus dual for instance
you can even Stick it to an ITX build
and still play with r tracing on uh in
4k but you know what I still want to end
this video with some food for thought so
I've been asking myself am I just happy
about the value that the RTX 470 is
providing simply because because how bad
I thought the ti was also since when
have we all collectively accepted that
3,49 ring or
$599 is the price point for mid-range
gaming for some context you can get the
PS5 for around 2,000 ring here in
Malaysia and a 4K TV would go for as low
as 1299 ring and that is everything I
have to say about the RTX 4070 if you
thought this video was helpful don't
forget to like and share so that more
people will see this video also leave a
comment down below if you have any
questions regarding the RTX 4070 and
I'll try my best to reply to you also
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
that notification Bell to see more
content like this and don't forget to
follow us on Tik Tok Facebook and
Instagram to see more Shenanigans From
the Mob House crew and just hang out and
chat with you know the team again my
name is bangaan Shane and I will see you
in the next one
[Music]